>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Manuel Roig-Franzia:
Mark's current book is called
"Havana: A Subtropical Delirium."
I think you'll find it
a very interesting book.
He takes you to some places in
Havana in this really magical
and very special city that
I think you would not get
if you were just reading the
headlines about Cuba today.
He takes you to the cemetery
where people go to pray
for their pregnant wives,
because a corpse had been found
with the child in the mother's arms.
And he takes you into the kitchens
where people are making these
incredible Cuban dishes.
And I loved the recipe but said,
"Kill the chicken with the machete.
Chop up the chicken
with the same machete."
With that, I introduce
Mark Kurlansky.
Please give him a big hand.
[ Applause ]
>> Mark Kurlansky: Thank you.
A pleasure to be here.
You know, these days if you
travel around the world,
Washington DC has a reputation for
kind of ignorance and backwardness.
But here we are, writers
and readers together,
showing that there's
another Washington
and there's another America.
[ Applause ]
This book came about because the
publisher Bloomsbury was doing a
series where they asked
different writers to write
about a city that they loved.
A small, somewhat personal book.
Somebody did Paris and somebody did
Florence and somebody did Prague.
And then they said, "Oh, why don't
we get Kurlansky to to do Havana?"
And there is a certain
amount of logic to this.
I've been going to Havana fairly
regularly since the early 1980s.
But also, I am a guy you should
get to write about the city.
You know, it's like
I'm not a naturalist.
I'm an urbanist.
I love cities.
And I love the Caribbean.
I've written four or five books
books about the Caribbean.
I'm losing track, but
a bunch of books.
And Havana is the great
Caribbean city.
This was an opportunity for me
but it's a somewhat personal book
and a small book in
the traditional style.
In my tradition, it also goes on
to talk about culture and food
and all things I keep talking about.
The subtitle, "A Tropical
Delirium," it's a quote from a quote
from a Cuban novelist,
Emilio Estevez,
a book called "Los Palacios
Distantes," in which he wrote
of Havana, "This subtropical
delirium under the sun by the edge
of a beautiful bay,
diabolically beautiful,
open to the perilous waters
of the Gulf of Mexico,
swarming with sharks
and lost souls."
That's about as great a description
of Havana as I've ever heard.
My own description of
Havana is that it's
like an unshaven man
wearing a tattered tuxedo.
Havana is very tattered nowadays.
People blame it on the
revolution, you know,
in a sort of compulsive way will
accept that charge and say, "Well,
it's the fault of the embargo.
We couldn't get any paint."
But the choice is that Havana has
always been somewhat tattered.
If you go back and look
at Walker Evans photos
from the 30s, it looks tattered.
And in literature the 19th
and even 18th century,
they describe how tattered
and crumbling it is.
What happens with Havana is
that there's a neighborhood
where everybody wants to live.
Originally it was what we now call
[Foreign Language], Old Havana.
Some wealthy people built big
mansions and then new styles
of architecture come and wealthy
people want to have a different kind
of house and more space, so
they moved out beyond the wall
to the Prado, and then they moved
to [Foreign Language],
and then on to Miramar.
As they move on, these big fabulous
homes are kind of abandoned.
And the thing about the tropics
is that it eats buildings.
If you do not repair them
constantly, they fall apart.
So the buildings that
they are taking care of,
for instance Hemingway's house,
they are repairing almost nonstop.
So buildings that get left
behind are really falling apart
and that's the look of Havana.
It's a hot place, that you
can go in January or February
and it will be 70 degrees,
maybe even a little cooler,
which is very pleasant.
But I always tell people,
"Don't go then,
because you're not really
experiencing Havana."
You want to be in Havana,
it's got to be really hot
and you've got to be sweating.
Havana is all about sweat.
Everybody sweats, you know.
In this country, you don't sweat.
In Miami, which has pretty much the
same climate, nobody sweats in Miami
because nobody is out
of air conditioning
for more than 30 seconds.
But in Havana, it's part of life.
You read almost any piece
of literature from Havana,
and they describe people sweating.
Sweating was the original
classlessness, you know.
Everybody sweats.
In [Inaudible] great novel,
[Foreign Language],"The Chase,"
there's this description of women in
the opera wearing furs and sweating.
People are outside and
they are walking around.
Habaneros, if they go to Miami then
they go to Little Havana in Miami
and expect to find something like
Havana, they come back, they say,
"Oh, Little Havana, that
was nothing like Havana.
There was nobody on the street."
Guillermo Cabrera Infante,
who was probably the funniest
writer Cuba ever produced,
has a scene in his book
about Havana in the 1950s.
Three guys are walking down
the street and he says,
"And you know they were Habaneros
because they were walking
down the middle of a street."
Sidewalks are narrow and crumbling
and everybody just works
through the streets.
They walk in the traffic.
Walking and sweating is
the life and have been up.
My first trip to Havana
was in the early 1980s,
and I was a newspaper
correspondent in Mexico City.
And the Cuban ambassador
to Mexico invited a bunch
of correspondents to come to Havana.
He was a very affable
man whose nickname
for me was Emohito [phonetic].
I have no idea why.
So a bunch of us correspondents
were going to Havana,
and we were in the press room at the
US Embassy waiting for a briefing
from the ambassador, and we were all
talking about this upcoming trip.
And the CIA guy came in.
He said, "You're Americans,
you can't go to Havana."
And we informed him that we could
because we were correspondents
and we were going.
So right there is going to
be a great trip, you know,
because there's nothing
greater than going somewhere
after the CIA tells you you can't.
And that Havana, very
different from Havana today,
was subsidized by the Soviet union.
And it was an experimental
society where everything was new
and everything was an experiment.
One of the great advantages
of not being a democracy is you
do something, if it doesn't work,
you say, "Whoops, well, now
we're going to do this instead."
And they were just trying
out all sorts of things.
They changed wedding vows.
You were at your wedding,
the groom vowed to do a share
of the housework, and
all these things.
And they put us up at Havana Libre,
which used to be the Havana Hilton
and was the newest hotel in Havana.
Still probably the
newest hotel in Havana.
It opened just shortly
before the revolution.
Sort of a sterile high-rise
building.
The phones are all
tapped, so that's why they
like to put the journalists
in there.
They were very proud of this.
They had all these agents
that hung out in the lobby.
And you'd be on the phone and you
make an appointment with somebody
for lunch, and then
you go downstairs
to leave the hotel to go to lunch.
And this guy would come up
to you and he'd say, "Oh,
so you're meeting so-and
so at the Floradita?
That's great."
They wanted you to know
that they were listening.
It wasn't a problem.
That Havana was such
a different world.
There were very few
restaurants, very few hotels.
And very few Americans.
Being an American in Havana was
oddly okay, in spite of the fact
that our government was
trying to starve them.
Nobody seemed to have any
bad feelings about Americans.
They still don't.
I can't explain that, except that
it's famously a characteristic
of Habaneros, that they just
love foreigners of all kinds.
So this book is not
really a history book.
The Indian historian
[Inaudible] once said that
"History is the rear-view mirror
that is the crystal ball."
So if you really want to understand
Havana and you want to get some idea
of what might be happening
in the future,
you have to look at the history.
And one of the things that's really
characteristic of Havana history is
that there's always been change.
I mean, people talk about
how there's change now,
but the change that's
going on in Havana
and Cuba now are minor compared
to the changes that went
on in the early 1990s after the
collapse of the Soviet Union,
which of course in turn were also
minor compared to the changes
that went on in the 1960s when the
revolution was getting started.
And you can go back and back,
and there's always these changes.
Havana was founded three times,
different places all called Havana.
The first one was on the southern
coast in the malarial swamp
and everybody was getting sick.
The southern coast is a mistake.
This happens in Caribbean countries.
They want to put a city
on the southern coast
because it's the Caribbean.
It's a calm, very beautiful water.
But the rougher Atlantic side is
actually where you want to be,
because then you have direct access
to North America and
Mexico and Europe.
It's in the shipping line.
If you're on the southern
side, you have to go
through a treacherous
passage between islands get
out into the shipping lines.
So this malarial swamp where they
were living called Havana happened
to be on the thinnest
part of the island.
So it was a very short move
to get to the north coast
where they found another
malarial swamp to settle in.
And then somebody realized
that it's not good to live
in malarial swamps in the tropics.
And there was this place not
far away that had high ground
and an incredible deep water
port with a narrow opening,
so it was very sheltered.
And so they moved there and that
became the Havana that we know now.
So the Spanish took
everything he stole from Mexico
and they dropped it off in
Havana to move it on to Spain.
And every pirate in
the Caribbean knew
that all this loot was
lying around in Havana.
So Havana was constantly raided
by pirates and by everybody
and was burned to the ground
several times and often looted.
This is the way of life in Havana.
The streets were very narrow
because it was more defendable
and they were just always
braced for the next attack.
The final attack, 1762,
the British attacked.
The British government
had their own reasons.
They just wanted to hold
Havana so they could trade it
for something else,
Florida actually,
which some people have said was
a mistake but it's our good.
So the commander of the British
forces inspired his troops
by saying, "Come on
lads, let's attack Havana
and we'll all be rich as Jews."
And they were.
They got absolutely nothing.
There was no loot lying around,
and the British soon left.
The Spanish then sealed
off the harbor with chains,
built a wall around the city,
and at nighttime they
would put out with chains.
They would lock all the gates to
the city and they would fire cannons
to let you know that Havana
was sealed in for the night.
Isn't it interesting that
they still fire those cannons.
I mean, the chains are gone, the
walls gone, the gates are gone.
But there's still that
psychological thing
in the tradition letting people know
that you're sealed in for the night.
Foreigners go to Havana and they
see this beautiful blue ocean
with a purple stripe
that is the Gulfstream,
which is why Hemingway moved there.
And they think, "Oh,
this is beautiful.
This is wonderful.
What a great setting."
Habaneros hate the sea.
They have a dread of the sea.
The most famous Havana writer José
Marti wrote [inaudible] fear I hate
the sea.
The reason they hate the sea
is because of the bad things
that are going to come from the sea.
Habaneros are always ready prepared
for invasion, even matchbooks
which of course like everything
else are made by the government,
and the matchbooks say on
it "Ready for Defense."
Charles Makowski, the
American writer,
once wrote that the definition
of a paranoid was a man
in possession of all the facts.
When you look at the history
of Cuba and you look at Havana
and why Havana is so different
from the rest of Cuba,
the distinct characters,
social characteristics of Cuba,
you have to look at slavery.
Cuba has the longest
history of slavery
of any place in the Americas.
The barbarism of it
is beyond imagination.
It was the first slaving country
in the Americas in the beginning
of the 1500s, and slavery
remained in Cuba until 1886.
It was so recent that when I first
went to Cuba, I would meet people
who knew your grandparents
who were African-born slaves.
So it's something we
haven't gotten over,
but it's even more
recent for Cubans.
There was a division in
Cuba which remained --
there was this one
side, the slavers.
The people ask sometimes why
Cuba stayed a Spanish colony
so much longer than anywhere
else in the Americas.
The reason is that the landowning
slaveowning oligarchy wanted the
Spanish so that the Spanish
army could protect them
from slave uprisings.
So you had the wealthy
pro-slave side, pro-Spanish,
and you had the people who wanted
independence who were abolitionists.
And this was the complete breakdown.
And it remained till
the Cuban revolution,
the Castro '59 revolution
when Castro took power.
The first people to
leave Cuba and turn
against the revolution were the
descendents of the landowners
who had been pro- Spanish
and had had slaves.
The early and the long-standing
enthusiasts
of the revolution were
people who had come
from the the abolitionist
pro-independent anti-Spanish people,
including, of course,
people of color.
Which is why non-Cuban people
in Miami don't understand
that Cuba is largely a black country
because all the Cubans
in Miami are white.
What made Havana very different
from the rest of Cuba is
that it was the largest
free black population.
And the reason for that was that in
Spanish law, a slave had the right
to buy his or her freedom.
But of course, there's a catch, and
that is that if you were a slave
at a sugar plantation, you
don't have any opportunity
to earn money to buy your freedom.
But if you were a slave
in a household in Havana,
there were various things you
could do on the streets of Havana,
including prostitution or selling
something or all kinds of things
that many earned money
and bought their freedom.
So there was this large
free population.
There was also a large
mixed population,
especially because slaveowners would
have relations with their slaves,
and the mixed children
were automatically free.
But these free blacks and mixed did
not have the status of white people.
They were not allowed to
be called senor or senora.
They were not allowed
in certain restaurants,
certain seats in the
theater, certain jobs.
There were people in between who
were struggling for position.
And among these people were women
of mixed blood called mulattas,
and mulatta is still very much a
part of Cuban culture and the ideas
that mulattas are beautiful
sexual creatures.
This is all profoundly
based on racism and sexism,
and it was about these
women struggling
for some kind of a standing.
If you had a relationship
with a wealthy white person,
that would improve your status.
And so, there was this
reputation and it endures,
this idea that mulattas are
incredible sexual figures.
A lot of things endure.
There's a novel, "Cecelia
Valdez," which is the central novel
of Havana literature the same
way Don Quixote is in Spain
or Les Miserables to Paris
or some of Dickens to London.
By a writer named Cirilo Villaverde,
who actually like José Marti,
lived most of his life
in New York in exile.
And it's the story of the
unfair tragic life of a mulatta,
and the book is dedicated
to the women of Cuba.
And it's incredible to read
because it has great
detailed descriptions of life.
You know, if you want to see life
in 19th-century Havana,
just read this book.
Havana, more than anywhere else in
Cuba, is a place of African culture.
The most practiced religion
in Havana is Santeria
which is basically the religion
of the Urobas [phonetic]
of West Africa, Nigeria.
And you know, revolutions
are kind of like --
you ever play this game with
your kids, opposite day?
That's what revolutions are like.
It's opposite day.
Before the revolution,
Santeria was outlawed,
and the Catholic Church
was the established church.
So the revolution was
anti-Catholic Church,
and so everybody wanted
to be a Santero.
The religion, back when it was
outlawed, was hidden in Catholicism,
so all the African spirits
are hidden in Catholic saints.
So [Inaudible] who heals the sick,
is represented as St. Lazarus.
And there is a Catholic
Church shrine to Saint Lazarus
on the outskirts of Havana, and once
a year everybody makes pilgrimages
there, and the few
Catholic clergy left
in Havana say, "Oh, look at this.
People still really
care about Catholicism."
But most of the people who are
going there are going there
for Babalú Ayé, which yes,
is the Desi Arnez song.
The Desi Arnez song is
about the Santeria spirit.
Music, of course, is of African
roots and the main tradition
of Havana music is a song which
was not first created in Havana
but it took over Havana,
and it was also outlawed
but has remained deep
in the culture.
An anthropologist in Havana
once told me that if you look
at Habaneros sort of idly
tapping their fingers,
you'll see that they're
always beating
out song, which is a great idea.
So every time somebody is tapping
out their fingers, I try to listen,
but I've never really gotten it.
What I have noticed is that you
hear music everywhere in Havana,
partly because there's no windows.
There's rod-iron gratings and no
glass so that breezes can blow
through and everybody has music in
their homes in addition to the fact
that there's live music in all
of the bars and restaurants.
So as you walk down
the street in Havana,
you're just hearing music
after music after music.
And when the music is sung, which
is quite often, you watch people.
There's a peculiar saunter
of Habaneros, and yes,
it's exactly to the rhythm of song.
Somebody became famous in
the rest of the world in 1928
when a singer named Rita
Montaner sang the song called
"El Manisero, the Peanut Vendor."
There used to be lots of street
vendors in Havana and this is a song
to the street vendor and
it's about buy your peanuts,
these peanuts are delicious.
You can go on YouTube
and you can get a film
of Rita Montaner singing
"El Manisero."
It's extraordinary.
She's in this state of
ecstasy, what I call my book
"delirium" about the peanut vendor.
Of course, this being Cuba,
everybody insists, "Ah yeah,
well it's not really about peanuts."
I don't know, but catch the film.
It's tremendous.
People in Havana have a
particular way of talking.
They don't speak Spanish
like anywhere else,
and that is also an
African influence.
It's kind of like words are very
hot and they have to spit them
out of their mouth
as fast as possible.
They drop a lot of
syllables and they drop a lot
of phonemes, especially S's and R's.
There's no S's and R's, which seems
to be an African characteristic.
In Haitian Creole, there's
no S's or R's either.
So people from Havana always
called me Guillanki [phonetic],
which I think is kind of nice.
"Hey, Guillanki."
They have this way of speaking,
this S and R-less way of speaking.
When the S is gone, they
replace it with an aspiration.
So mas o menos, which means more
or less, in Havana is maco meno.
Although I am fluent in Spanish,
it always takes me about a day
in Havana to start understanding
what people are saying.
But Fidel Castro was not
from Havana, and he spoke --
and also he was a lawyer
-- he spoke very clearly
and was easy to understand.
All the journalists loved
the way Fidel Castro spoke.
They is , "God, I wish everybody
in Havana spoke like Fidel.
I can understand him."
Another essential of Havana and
of Cuba in general is baseball.
In Cuban baseball,
there's no trading players,
so everybody plays their entire
career for their hometown,
which means that Havana
has the best teams
because they can draw
from 2 million people.
And some of these teams are
drawn from 50,000 people.
So you have people like
[Inaudible] who plays for the Mets.
Said he didn't leave Cuba
for political reasons.
He left it for an opportunity in
baseball, because if he stayed
in Cuba, he would have been playing
for his small town,
but never one forever.
So what does he do?
He goes to the Mets.
In Cuban ballparks, the only
snack they serve as Cuban coffee
in these incredible pieces of paper
that they fold into an espresso cup.
And near the fifth inning, they go
out and serve coffee to the umpires
that they've been cursing
for the past five innings.
That is a much better system
than in the rest of Cuba
where they only serve lollipops.
Have you ever tried
to curse somebody
out while you're sucking a lollipop?
It's just not effective.
But the thing to understand
about Cuban baseball players
in this country is how they come
here and at first they're not really
as good as they were supposed to be.
You've got to remember that this
guy is playing for the first time
in his life in a ballpark
where he doesn't know anybody.
Even when they do an
away game in Cuba,
everybody from the hometown
piles into these trucks and buses
and goes to wherever the game is.
So now they are in this
place with huge stands
and nothing but strangers.
A strange thing happened to me.
I was approached some years
ago by Gourmet Magazine.
In the early 90s, they
wanted me to go to Cuba
and do an article gourmet, and this
was at a time after the Soviets left
when Cuba was really
struggling to have enough food.
And I said "Yeah, this really isn't
a good time to write about food."
And they said, "Oh no, you
don't have to write about food.
Write about whatever you like."
I said, "Well, I like baseball."
They said, "Okay, great.
Go and write about baseball."
So I spent two weeks in Havana
doing nothing but going to one
or two baseball games
everyday all over the island.
And when I was staying in Havana,
I stayed at a hotel called
La Parque Central which is,
of course, by the Parque Central.
And I picked this spot
because it's a spot
in the Parque Central
called the esquina caliente,
and esquina caliente an
expression for third-base.
It means the hot corner because
third base here at 90 feet
from home plate, you've
got to make decisions fast.
But this esquine caliente is a place
where baseball fans gather
every morning to argue
about the games the night before.
So I thought I'd go
and I'd listen to them.
There is no way I would participate.
If you didn't understand
Spanish,you would think
that this was some
violent political argument.
But it's just baseball.
It's Havana delirium.
So I was staying at the Parque
Central and I was out one day
to see an Industriales game, and
Industriales is a Havana club.
It's the most winning
club in Cuban baseball.
And I'm walking through the lobby
and the porter comes up to me.
He says, "I've got a woman for you."
I said, "No, no.
I've got to get going."
And he says, "But she's a mulatta."
And this is an interesting thing,
because in Havana syllables are
never carefully enunciated except
for those three -- mulatta.
And I look over in the corner
and there's this woman
blowing me kisses.
I said to the guy, "No, sorry,
I got to go to a baseball game."
And he says -- his whole
tone of voice says "Really?
Who's playing?"
I said it's the Industriales,
they're playing Santiago.
Industriales and Santiago
is a little bit
like the Yankees and the Red Sox.
He says, "Who's starting
for Industriales?"
I said Rene [Inaudible].
He said, "Oh, he's not so good."
The woman in the corner
isn't blowing kisses anymore.
She's getting more and more
angry while the guy goes
through the entire Santiago lineup,
explaining how [Inaudible] should
pitch to each of these hitters.
By the end, he was almost
ready to quit his job
and go to the ballgame with me.
That's Havana.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
We have a few minutes left.
I'd love to take some questions
if anyone wants to ask anything.
I can't really see you
but there's microphones.
So if you want to ask a question --
>> I have a question.
When you're studying the culture, it
sounds like you know it very well,
how do you overcome any
obstacles, either through language,
restrictions on place,
where you can go,
or maybe people telling you
something you may not believe is
true, or restrictions on access to
places you just can't go in Cuba.
How do you get to a point,
which sounds like you have,
where you know what
you're talking about
and you really believe what you've
seen and heard you can confirm it,
you're comfortable with it?
>> Mark Kurlansky: Well,
language is kind of essential.
I've been speaking
Spanish since I was a kid.
I originally learned
from Puerto Ricans.
And you know, some
things you can't --
you have to operate differently
in different countries.
Cuba isn't a country where you
can get everything confirmed
by the Cuban government.
It's also a country where you can't
work without the Cuban government.
They get very uneasy if
you're talking to people
without them knowing about it.
Baseball in particular, you
know, this one of these things
where you wouldn't think about it,
but talking to baseball
players makes them very nervous
because there's major-league
scouts that are going around trying
to talk these guys into defecting.
So, you know, who's this guy really?
You just have to learn to
work with these difficulties.
I mean, it's a little
difficult in Cuba.
Listen, it's more difficult
in Mexico
because the Mexican government is
just really difficult to work with.
It's just part of the game you play.
You learn how to play it.
It's sometimes frustrating.
Yeah, there are places you
can't go, though not too many.
Not too many, and most of the places
you can't go aren't places I'm
particularly interested in
anyway, because I really don't care
that much about military bases.
So you just learn to deal with it.
Yeah?
>> I have a question for you.
You might be the guy who has a one
word title, but you're also a guy
who really tends to focus on these
grand global transnational sort
of stories.
So I was curious how
it felt to change that
and to really limit your scope a
little bit, and also how you feel
like your background as more
of a global transnational
historian has helped you
in limiting that scope to Havana?
>> Mark Kurlansky:
Well, it felt great.
All my books aren't
on global things.
I've done other books that were,
you know, very narrowly focused,
and I've done fiction
books on particular places.
I've done all kinds of
things, but I enjoyed very much
when this was proposed to me, the
idea of just focusing on Havana.
I mean, I didn't even
want to do Cuba.
I just wanted to do Havana.
That was something that I enjoyed.
I supposed it took some discipline
because the reason I do these global
books is I kind of think like that
and everything just keeps expanding.
Fortunately, this was
a fairly short book
so I could stop it before
it got out to the world,
and just keep it focused on Havana.
Yeah?
>> Can I ask you about
a different book?
>> Mark Kurlansky: Okay.
>> Since we are at a
Library of Congress event,
I wonder if you could talk about
how you got the idea for "Food
of a Younger Land" and what it
was like to work with the LOC
to have access to those records?
>> Mark Kurlansky: Well, this
would be the place to ask me that.
Yeah, "Food of the Younger Land"
was a book that I did entirely
in the Library of Congress
from an archive there
of WPA writings on food.
It was a very pleasant experience
to just go to the Library
of Congress every day and put on
my little gloves, get these files
and look through these old onion
skin carbon copies of stuff
that people had written
in the 1930s.
I just tremendously enjoyed it.
I mean, the Library of Congress --
I'm not saying this because
we're here, but we are here --
is a great place to work.
They are all set up for people like
me who want to do things like that.
>> A question over here.
First of all, thank you so much.
I was just in Havana in June and it
has filled in a lot of gaps for me.
I'm curious how you have seen the
hopes of the Cuban people change
over the decades that
you've been there?
The hopes of the people,
so the hopes
and dreams of the Cuban people.
>> Mark Kurlansky: The hopes --
>> Yeah.
>> Mark Kurlansky: Well, you know,
at the time of the revolution,
young people, and not
just young people,
people were very excited
about the revolution.
Getting rid of their -- it was
almost like trying to get rid
of their entire history, pushing
out all of the Spanish stuff
and the slave stuff and
all the burdens of history
and creating this new society.
It felt very exciting, you know.
As I said, it felt like
this experimental society
where you would try
all of these things.
But it was based on a bargain.
The bargain was, the Cuban
government said you're not going
to get rich.
You are to abandon
materialism and just contribute
to your society in any way you can.
And in exchange for that,
we will look after you.
We'll give you your housing.
We'll give you your food.
We'll give you your education.
We'll give you your healthcare.
And that worked reasonably well
until the collapse
of the Soviet Union.
Then suddenly, there
wasn't enough money.
What the government was providing
wasn't enough for people.
The government started allowing
people to do other things,
like open their own restaurants.
And as soon as you open that window
of capitalism of making money
for yourself, suddenly you know,
like doctors are complaining
that they aren't getting
paid enough.
They never used to
complain about that.
The government made them doctors
and this was their
social responsibility.
That whole thing kind
of fell apart as soon
as you opened this
window of capitalism.
>> Thank you.
This is really amazing.
I'm looking forward
to reading your book,
having read some of your others.
I had a chance to live in the
Caribbean for quite a while.
And while I was there, got
introduced to the music style
of the Nueva Trova, which was
very popular after the revolution,
and Silvio Rodriguez and people
like that talking about places
like Playa Giron and really
emphasizing the cultural identity
of the people.
And I was just curious
to know how evoking
that passion has really moved
forward in terms of the importance
of that style of music, that
style of culture in modern Cuba,
especially in light of the political
changes that are occurring.
>> Mark Kurlansky: Yeah.
Well, it's still very much around.
And those concerts are still
tremendously popular and,
by the way, cost almost
nothing to go to.
It remains a strong tradition and
a lot of those singers from back
in the 60s are still singing.
Also [inaudible] and
all sorts of things.
Cuba doesn't seem to
lose music forms.
It just keeps adding to them.
I'm facing this sign that says
"Wrap it up" in large red letters.
So I'm sorry I can't -- Well,
do you have a quick question?
>> I was going to say, since
you were a food writer,
I'd like to hear something
about the food of Havana.
>> Mark Kurlansky:
That's a quick question?
Well, you know, food in
Cuba is Cuban history,
so it's a little bit Spanish
and it's a little bit African
and sometimes it's a
little bit of Indian in it.
And there's a bunch
of American in it.
It's a mixture of all those cultures
that have passed through Havana.
I think that's it.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Okay, I'm going to be
signing books somewhere.
I have no idea where,
but you probably know.
So see you there.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov.